c'est une information très sérieuses
dont bfm s'est fait l'écho il ya
quelques jours ci à l'elysée la cote de
popularité en baisse des manuels macro
interroge sur sa capacité à être réélu
en 2022 pour les proches du président ce
ne sont pas les autres partis qui serait
dangereux mais bel et bien l'émergence
d'un candidat surprise que personne
n'attend en effet selon les informations
exclusives de la chaîne info les
conseillers du président craindre et
l'arrivée dans la course à l'elysée d'un
candidat à la coluche et ce candidat
surprise pourrait être cyril hanouna
selon eux son rapport au public
particulier sa forte communauté et son
intérêt pour les sujets de société qui
l'a prouvé avec balance son poste en
ferait le candidat idéal pour contrer un
responsable politique traditionnelle
alors cyril hanouna va-t-il être
candidat en 2022 alors déjà est ce que
vous y croyez ici autour de la table
avant qu'on ait la vie de franck roi
kiro et de florian cindy qui dit la
vérité vous est-ce que vous avez déjà
entendu parler de cette rumeur oui il ou
pas du tout oui j'ai entendu parler et
je pense que comme le chaos s'installe
un peu en france situation politique
très compliqué les gens pensent que tout
devient possible
et il ya d'ailleurs quelques modèles qui
ont émergé en europe des migrants
voilà des humoristes qui sont arrivés au
pouvoir ou très près du pouvoir donc je
pense que c'est pris au sérieux ça c'est
sûr j'ai lu ardennes
oui en fait vous commencez à faire peur
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que les deux
invités de marque
mais pour marc il n'ya pas d'invité
politique ce soir c'est vrai ce que vous
avez demandé vos équipes ont demandé ils
nous l'ont dit a beaucoup de politiques
de venir réagir personne n'a voulu
réagir parce que c'est un sujet qui
fâche pourquoi il ya eu des candidatures
comme coluche et beppe grillo need a
listé des candidatures de protestation
avec ce qui s'est passé pour les gilet
jaune moi c'est quelqu'un même d'états
majors politiques qui m'a dit ça avec ce
qui s'est passé sur les gilet jaune
la manière dont vous avez fait parler
les gens votre proximité populaire et
pas populiste mme vous fait peur parce
que pour la première fois quelqu'un hors
du cercle politique pour incarner une
candidature d'espérance c'est plus basé
sur la protestation se serait sur
l'espérance et la croyance des gens vous
fait peur et ils ont peur que ça monte
sur les premiers sondages qui pourrait
sortir bientôt assez haut
peut-être même comme coluche en 95 a
atteint 15% alors justement on va
paraître coluche parce que c'est
l'exemple qui était d'ailleurs coluche
et on tété
aujourd'hui on top tweets ça m'a fait
bien plaisir ce que je suis je suis fan
absolu de coluche le voc 9 octobre 80 il
ya presque 40 ans coluche organise une
conférence de presse pour déclarer sa
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
de
80 alors sa part d'une vanne au début et
ça commence à devenir sérieux lorsque
les sondages le créditent de plus de 16%
d'intentions de vote et de beaucoup de
soutien comme eddy mitchell michel et
michel sardou des intellectuels son
slogan de campagne s'était jusqu'à
présent la france est coupée en deux
avec moi elle sera pliée en k4 alors
vous a préparé un petit magnéto
avant/après de coluche l'humoriste à
coluche le politique qui après bien sûr
on aura l'analyse de franck et de
florian d'accord mais la candidature est
très sérieuse dans la mesure où je fais
plus de chances d'avoir des voix que les
autres candidats qui se présentent quoi
tout simplement c'est que justement les
petits fours qui je me présente
il n'existe pas en politique c'est à
dire tout le monde les prendre pour rien
quoi mais simplement ce que je leur
propose c'est de renvoyer le compliment
hommes politiques
alors donc que je dirais que c'était
monte monte monte monte valérie bnm est
ce que vous avez devant vous de cette
rumeur oui alors revenu ses revenus au
moment de l'élection du président
ukrainien où on a beaucoup beaucoup fait
le parallèle en disant c'était un homme
de c'est un homme de télé c'était un
humoriste à la télé il faisait des
sketches et c est tout et ses revenus à
mes oreilles le fait qu'effectivement on
évoquait votre candidat avant votre
éventuelle candidature jean-michel je
n'avais pas spécialement tourné en
france non tunisie énormément parce que
quand je vous ai assez régulièrement
tunisie et tout le monde m'a arrêté pour
me dire à votre série des fantastiques
et quand est-ce qu'il se présente à la
présidentielle en tunisie les gens vous
réclame là bas c'est incroyable alors en
france 5 ne saviez pas besoin qu'on la
baisse alors choisir qu'il faut savoir
c'est que je pense c'est fait pas rire
du tout ok une vraie inquiétude parce
que si on peut vous venir en politique à
passion cette élection fait pas rire du
tout parce qu'effectivement si jamais
vous était candidat et vous feriez 18
15%
ce serait une catastrophe nucléaire-
s'associe avec 15% qui vous étaient
attribués les conséquences pour un
second tour serait énorme
voilà je sais pas s'il voulait le
président vous et nous nous répondre se
détourner d'un mois tous les cas je
pense que c'est pas la première fois
coluche l'avait fait mon grand père
avait fait je sais qu'il s'était mis aux
gens ils m'ont tant il avait à l'époque
que 12 13 14 15 concentre note et je me
rappelle qu'à l'époque déjà on lui avait
clairement fait comprendre que ce serait
très bien qu'il se retire du jeu
politique est assez rapidement ça ne
fait pas rire du tout hein
il avait un important
effectivement à part les airs tel il ya
des gens qui sont venus nous voir en
disant notamment du service politique en
disant mais c'est quoi c'est quoi cette
histoire est ce que ces séries lui même
qui fait courir ce bruit dit maintenant
pas du tout moi j'ai entendu le rush de
garantie que son plateau série ne nous a
jamais dit je veux me présenter tous et
n'est effectivement des milieux
politiques et j'aimerais avoir juste
qu'ils qui a commandé ce sondage qui
apparemment existe quand même
alors on frank tapiro vous qu'est ce que
vous en pensez et parce que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui c'était un déferlement
juin cinquante mille appels j'ai vu un
et pleins d'articles vous êtes
communiquant cet ancien conseiller de
nicolas sarkozy
d'où est partie cette rumeur alors je
pense que sa part d'une peur et ça a été
dit sa part nulle part des politiques
vous savez très bien les défiances only
du grand public des français face aux
politiques parce qu'ils n'arrivent plus
à se connecter avec leur réalité et sa
part d'une peur pourquoi parce que déjà
le l'actuel président est venu nulle
part on connaissait pas et du jour au
lendemain en deux en même pas deux ans
tu as réussi à être président et surtout
il n'a pas fait que être président il a
humilié la classe politique française il
a fait exploser l'échiquier politique
s'il y en a un look il a rebattu les
cartes
et donc aujourd'hui il ya à la fois une
nouvelle peur c'est de se dire mais
finalement si ça a été possible une fois
j'ai fait le slogan 2007 tout devient
possible
quand je te veux dire oui quand nicolas
sarkozy que la sarkozie mais tout
devient possible et la peur ça serait de
voir quelqu'un venu de nulle part venir
contester la présidence de manuel da
cruz lors du prochain du prochain
scrutin et donc on se dit mais l'homme
peut venir de n'importe où et ben
n'importe où ça peut être aussi un
comédien un comique un humoriste un
présentateur télé et vous être sortis
pour voir tout simplement parce que
j'avais deux qualités qui font défaut
aujourd'hui politique d'abord vous
rassemblez pas seulement des
téléspectateurs les spectateurs des gens
des français sont d'accord mou et même
ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord avec vous
vous reconnaissent vous laissait pas
indifférent première chose mais
deuxièmement vous avez quelque chose qui
manque furieusement à tous les
politiques
si vous êtes sincère et je pense vous
pouvez vous faire plein de procès mais
pas pro sans sincérité
donc c'est vrai que quelque part dans le
champ du possible même si ça paraît
incroyable comment on se dit à maurice à
présentateur télé mais ce n'est pas
possible c'est possible pourquoi mais
par défaut on va pas dire qu'on va leur
absolue vous êtes fait est né pour être
président mais par rapport à l'offre
politique aujourd'hui par rapport à tout
ce que des peaux utilisées surtout par
rapport à la diff
des français face aux politiques
finalement vous avez une forme de
crédibilité qui s'est créé avec le temps
donc moi presse je donnerai pas mon avis
parce que donc communicant politique
c'est vrai que je vous aime trop pour
vous conseiller
des candidats oui parce que si vous êtes
prêt à tout arrêter tout sacrifier tout
abandonné risque d'être hays et surtout
ce qui est pire d'être impopulaire
allez-y moi je vous conseille pas le
faire je vous aime trop pour ces
artistes vous signale que connu ça eu
peur au bout d'un moment elle a détruit
quelque part et les télés sérieux allez
on le voit dans ces attachants sérieux
mais ça avant avant qu'on ait la vidéo
et on va voir si un florian qui va nous
parler de tout ça on est à 10 dont la
rue demandé et vous débordez c'était une
bonne idée
regarde si un candidat avec son
présidentiel de 2022 qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
c'est une blague moi je passais une très
très bonne idée résidence et les dames
na m'en moque
est ce que vous pourriez voté pour cyril
hanouna oui bien sûr non non pourquoi
pas c'est quoi son programme déjà non
mais c'est pas sérieux quand j'ai dit
roy mais je n'imagine même pas en tant
que président en fait moi je rajouterais
pour cyril way pour lui oui ça mais qui
bien qu est naturel qui voilà qui
ferreira aux gens et là des ministres
potentiels atp mpc pas jean michel maire
pourra lui trouver un poste égal à santé
par exemple aussi avec quoi la santé
jean michel mr bah parce qu'ils
pourraient faire des cours d'éducation
sexuelle donc gratuit je n'imagine pas
en fait à la place de du président bras
quand je pense que c'est un canular
[Applaudissements]
d'avoir d'avoir répondu vous voyez ça ça
fait mal ça fait marrer les gens
oui c'est vrai que nous sommes aussi ça
va ça m'a fait marrer ce maillot vous
êtes expert en communication politique
fondateur de la french coop vous est ce
que vous avez entendu parler de cette
rumeur
voilà qui dit que le voilà le leuy fois
l'art gouvernement n'a peur d'une
candidature un petit peu bizarre un
petit show grenu et oui elle est
persistante depuis au-moins décembre
c'est un scénario qui est tout à fait
crédible pour un tas de raisons d'abord
il ya évidemment une défiance à l'égard
des politiques les français non
seulement il ne les entende plus mais il
ne les écoute plus alors qu'ils n'ont
jamais autant parlé la vérité aussi
c'est que aujourd'hui cyril vous êtes
plus libre que les politiques pouvaient
débattre plus facilement sans limites
sans contrainte alors que ces politiques
ils ont tout un tas de contraintes sur
ce qu'ils peuvent dire ou sur ce qu'ils
ont le sentiment de devoir dire
aujourd'hui le meilleur lieu on fait la
politique c'est ici et c'est pour ça
qu'un certain nombre de ministres
à mon sens ont eu raison de venir ici
tenter de renouer le contact avec un
certain nombre de français qui se sont
durablement éloigné des urnes et à qui
nos politiques ne peuvent plus parler
parce qu'ils ne parlent plus la même
langue que vous avez connu si on a passé
des images qui sont intéressantes mais
il disait aussi je veux que les
politiques sentent l'odeur de merde que
moi je respire au quotidien bien chez
les gilets jaunes si la figure de
coluche à la été aussi populaire et
aussi rassembleuse c'est aussi d'abord
parce qu'ils ont le sentiment qu'ils ne
peuvent pas dire aux politiques
actuelles
la difficulté de leur vie quotidienne et
tout cela on peut l'aborder librement
ici
la vérité c'est qu'un certain nombre de
positions aujourd'hui ne sont plus
tenables sur le débat public à part les
politiques eux-mêmes et donc tous ceux
qui sont libres de pouvoir dire aux
français ce qu'ils ont le sentiment
d'être la vérité est bien c'est quelque
chose dans les politiques sont privés
alors vous est ce que vous avez entendu
parler d'un sondage ou pas du tout il ya
cette vérité sont des biens sur moi je
ça me fait plutôt rire et encore
aujourd'hui j'ai entendu des membres de
cabinets ministériels me dire mais cinq
six dix c'est absolument énorme ça peut
faire bousculer une élection
présidentielle oui ça peut tout changer
dans une élection présidentielle la
vérité c'est que je dis j'ai aussi
entendu un certain nombre de conseillers
me dire mais c'est un clown mais la
vérité c'est qu'ils portent eux la
responsabilité d'avoir transformé le jeu
politique en cirque et que le cloud
aujourd'hui il est plus puissant parce
qu'il est plus authentique plus
naturelle et donc les français se
reconnaissent davantage en lui quand
ceux qui sont aujourd'hui aux manettes
du pouvoir et ça de toute façon toutes
les candidatures qui pourrait émerger si
un jour vous vouliez être candidat mais
je crois que c'est sain pour la
démocratie y compris les candidatures
qu'ils sont un peu
poil à gratter bien au fond ça permet à
chacun de ces politiques de se réveiller
et de voir que les français ils ne se
contenteront pas de discours et qu'ils
veulent aujourd'hui des résultats
lorsqu'il met un bulletin dans une union
là eric naulleau qu'on puisse se poser
la question ça en dit long sur l'état de
la france c'est vraiment tout devient
possible donc là on en parle comme d'un
canular
si c'est pas vous ça peut être quelqu'un
d'autre qui émerge ainsi je pourrai
penser à quelqu'un d'autre
non mais après emmanuel matot avant on
me disait c'est bien aussi mais il n'a
pas d'assurance mais il n'a pas de parti
ça ne tient pas la route mais bien sûr
trump a beaucoup changé mais elle est
aussi énergique mignot on est sûrs
ronald reagan ya quelques années oui en
avril jean-louis jeu pas pourquoi tu dis
ça elle s'est pris comme un canular mais
je vois passer en tout cas pas cas
nuageux je trouve que la société ait
l'idée que les gens au-delà politique a
énormément bougé ces dernières années et
je trouve c'est la plus grosse aux
évidences et quand bourdin encore a
lancé une demande à quelqu'un qui est
candidat
la france a rouvert sous marin on s'en
fout complètement combien de ce malaise
l'essentiel c'est qu'ils aient déçu par
là et qu'ils soient opérationnels
voilà la led président attend sur une
vision une sensibilité un esprit
fédérateur c'est ça que les gens
perçoivent pour ça que les mouvements
sociaux troubles éclatent en ce moment
mais le les questions techniques on a dû
conseiller technique politique
économique on a des ministres pour faire
ça on n'a pas besoin de ça qu on est
président on s'oriente tout à fait apte
à être président alors en france il ya
bernard tapie voilà que j'aime beaucoup
le savent et qui s'était lancé en
politique alors qu'il était un homme
d'affaires à la base on a ressorti une
archive culte de bernard tapie en
politique c'était lors du départ face à
jean marie le pen regarde
parce que vous êtes un hâbleur vous êtes
notamment vous êtes un tartare à un
bluffeur
c'est pas parce que vous avez une grande
gueule et vous crier fort que vous
arrivez police et oui oui
la seule différence c'est que c'est pas
parce que vous affirmez fort quelque
chose que ce que vous dites est vrai
parce que vous dites n'importe quoi
monsieur vite revenir et c'est pas fini
vivement monsieur vous en cuir est parce
que vous avez vos gardes du corps n'ont
pas moins rigolo enfin regarder avant
d'être élu président des états unis en
2016 il a fait sa fortune dans
l'immobilier et surtout il a fait de la
télé où il était connu pour ses excès si
on vous a fait un petit avant après
regardez ça c'est énorme
[Applaudissements]
magnifique ça c'est une vraie image
imprimée faut dire que la société
américaine mais c'était français sont
vraiment totalement différente on les
compare mais c'est pas compris pourquoi
parce que on vit à travers les médias on
vient travers l'image depuis tout petit
ou vous apprendre à agir
ça c'est une caméra que ce soit quand
vous avez cinq ans à l'école ou sur un
terrain de foot baseball le football
américain
on voit déjà que toute la société
totalement son regard de l'autre donc
vous êtes dans les médias en permanence
donc vous devez dans la performance
médiatique
quel que soit finalement votre votre
métier lui on sait très bien qu'il vient
de l'immobilier du monde des affaires
il avait besoin de montrer qu'il était
un homme courageux un homme téméraire
que personne ne lui faisait peur tard il
a créé un une somme d'émotion incroyable
états unis et on pouvait pas rester
indifférent et c'est ça qu'on a du mal à
comprendre avec le phénomène de 30
les gens aiment être up ou détesté trump
et lui c'est vrai c'est à qui il
s'adressait au coeur des américains qui
n'adresse personnes en général donc au
fait personne ne l'a vu venir et en
faisant des prouesses comme ça on s'est
dit mais c'est pas possible en france
vous imaginez vous imaginez si le
nouveau être candidat
faire une prise de catch pareil c'est
impossible en forcené discréditer
immédiatement à mai mais ses rimes
faisant une prise de catch lendemain
d'un match de catch un peu peut-être
marcher mais pour un candidat classique
et traditionnelle non aux états unis oui
vraiment tu voulais je voulais réagir et
moi je voulais réagir parce que d'abord
je joue je vous connais très bien et si
si les hommes politiques comme vous avez
dit alors ils sont tournés vers eux
mêmes ils sont tournés vers eux mêmes
ils ne veulent plus parler aux français
ils se croient tout en haut il pense que
rien ne peut arriver pour eux il ya eu
le pen déjà deux fois au deuxième tour
c'est pas une vanne ans et deux fois ça
arrive et les deux pays donc ils pensent
que c'est fini ils disent voilà mais il
ya plus de gilet jaune c'est comme
j'entends souvent il y avait les gilet
jaune sont toujours alléger les jaunes
sont pas marrant surtout jour-là il
existe toujours que la misère elle se
cache c'est ça que les politiques ne
comprennent pas c'est que les gens qui
sont dans la misère ils sont ils se
vendent par dette dans la misère et se
cachent et quand ils iront dans une urne
pour voter ils ont le même pouvoir que
quelqu'un qui est riche
un pauvre il vote comme un riche c'est
la même chose c'est pareil et moi
pourquoi je me dis que si vous si vous
allez jusqu'au bout du truc ça peut
faire des dégâts parce que si on te
revend la même maillot
macron le pen et si on tenait à nouna
moi je suis persuadé qu'il ya plein de
gens qui vont dire - matheron le pen
j'en veux pas et par contre ana je veux
bien essayer et moi je vous dis quand
vous parlez avec les gens et tout ce que
vous essayez de faire pour les gens et
la sincérité cac a dit frank tapiro tout
ça c'est vrai tout ça c'est pas pour de
faux et les gens ils sont tellement
perdu politiquement savent pas où ils
vont politiquement et là ils disent moi
je veux que le vote blanc ils soient
comptés y en a qui disent moi j'y vais
pas parce que ça sert à rien acquis
votre n'importe quoi au premier tour ne
serait ce que 10 ou 12% vous foutez un
bordel monumental dans ces énormes de
vous [ __ ] un bordel j monument de la
qualité indispensable quand on se jette
dans l'arène politique
et vous l'avez avant même de vous citer
dans l'arène c'est l'absence de peur et
quelqu'un comme bernard tapie c'est pas
pour rien qu'on passe un extrait tout à
l'heure quelqu'un comme bernard tapie
moi je le connaissais bien il était
entré dans l'arène parce qu'il disait
non à l'extrême droite non à l'absence
de valeurs et je combats ça et vous vous
n'auriez pas peur de n'importe qui et en
ce moment vous avez déjà pris des
positions contre le communautarisme pour
des valeurs donc ça vous pouvez incarner
des choses qui toucherait les gens et
mes amis je trouve le parallèle encore
plus intéressant avec trump et je me
trompe peut-être mais vous avez cassé
les codes télé avant cacher des roues
cacher tout autant montrer les coulisses
la régie ou autre et aux étreintes qu il
a cassé les codes aussi c'est quand il
veut communiquer parce même plupart sont
que par son communiqué il prend son
tweet tweet quand même pas serré la
président de le serrer la main d'un
président démocrate il lui sert pas la
main au sensibles ou non voilà les gens
ont besoin de cette sincérité c'est pour
ça qu'il est aussi populaire
damien aussi beau bien votre dernière il
ya un truc qui fait beaucoup peur aux
politiques c'est sûr qu'ils surent qui
allez vous vous entourez ils savent très
bien que vous êtes capable de vous
entourer de gens de qualité savent très
bien que c'est pas nous on va pas y
aller nous sert très bien vous allez
prendre des gens complètement non mais
ça vous savez ça leur fait flipper c'est
parce qu'ils sont fidèles à dieu je tue
décide d'y aller pourquoi pas si ça se
trouve tu vas décidé d'y aller se disent
ils est d'emmener tout le monde moi je
suis persuadé qu'il ya des gens qui vont
te suivre parce que tu vas tu entouré de
gens compétents
on a vu le premier la première vague du
gouvernement macron qu'est-ce qui sait
qu'il a mis en ministre il a mis en
ministre tout et n'importe quoi excusez
moi de vous le dire mais il a mis tout
et n'importe quoi alors l'impression que
même mon téléphone il aurait pu sauver
les féministes des créneaux ministre
si c'est ça c'est ça son problème tout
cas la rumeur
juste cette rumeur est une très bonne
nouvelle chance pour la politique
pourquoi parce que ça bouge et ça va le
faire réagir donc c'est une excellente
nouvelle donc je ne sais pas si c'est
lui donne ce soir gmail mais le fait
déjà qu'on en parle
ça veut dire que vous imaginez ça m'a
fait rire shalit mais bien sûr quand
même pas comment c'est arrivé là bas
parce que j'ai jamais évoqué vraiment
les l'idée donc jamais jamais donc ça
d'abord la popularité léger les jeunes
mettaient la sincérité et surtout le
fait de rassembler les gens et à
montcenis mais qui à cette parole
politique parce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
un rôle politique
vous avez un rôle sociétal et l'autre
voie de travail vous avez une action
politique
finalement vous avez plus d'action
politique que les politiques aiment bien
ce système d' alerte qui est en train de
monter ou dix ans mais c'est un fantasme
une peur la peur de salir alors avec
vous que quelqu'un comme cyril hanouna
puisse se présenter et peut-être et on
l'espère le début d'une réaction
positive de la part des politiques qui
vont peut-être commencer à le dire comme
la plus sincère
comment agir 1 sur comment rassembler
plus de gens on l'espère sinon bah va
falloir y aller 1-1 doiron de rendre
l'antenne
moi je savais dans bref un oui la rumeur
est une bonne chose
oui une éventuelle candidature est une
bonne chose et non le fait d'y aller
pour moi n'est pas une gousse est pas
parce que vous êtes libre vous êtes
l'ipres vous êtes en dedans mais aussi
en dehors
je suis désolée la politique c'est aussi
des systèmes qui casse tant que vous
n'êtes plus fort et vous avez plus de
valeur en et en dehors que complètement
dedans je suis persuadé lorient vous
laisser une dernière chose oui un point
important c'est qu'il faut pas confondre
et j'entends aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de conseillers de ministres tout
confondre on peut faire de la politique
sans est engagé dans un parti politique
écologiste a montré que les restos du
coeur qu'on pouvait faire plus on est en
dehors du système partisan vos données
d'autres jeux plus et plus vite plus
faire dans l'associatif tout ça bah oui
me présenter à une élection
présidentielle voilà on est en train de
travailler sur mon ami poteau qui va
être une association qui va aider
énormément de gens je pense que la
priorité les plus la queue dans un
indécis dans un rôle politique 1 voilà
vous y avez cv une vraie pression c'est
à dire si vous étiez vraiment sollicité
le pod diriez vous
ya pas trop de pression ses
téléspectateurs deux ans pour 49% pire
certains parlent déjà résolu qu'époux
tomavo qui se paie les sondages est
arrivé plus tôt contre voyage 5000
votants en tout cas voilà pris ce matin
mais si vous voulez y aller il ya
peut-être une campagne qui pourrait être
bien pour vous quoi en fait vous aimez
bien rassembler un show tout ce public
est là tous les jours devant leur poste
enfin ce serait extraordinaire je
touchais que vous aimez vous détestez le
communautarisme zemit rassembler les
gens faire en sorte que les gens se
parlent se serait en fait plein de plans
de plein de gens différents qui
composent la france ils iraient tous la
france est à nous la france est à nous
la force est à nous elle est dit il a
fini sur la france est à new marais je
crois que ça prend bien
si les politiques sont plantés te dire
l'instant pour dire mais c'est quand
même sérieux la politique c'est sérieux
c'est très bien il était moi je sais
trop politique